in the mining town of Carosi the
desperate and poor are looking for
cobalt it's a vital component in
batteries used in goods ranging from
electric cars to phones and laptops more
than half of the world's cobalt is
produced in the Democratic Republic of
Congo tens of thousands of children are
estimated to be used to dig for the
toxic metal without a protective
clothing they are here with their
parents who say the whole family has to
work to survive
we are here because we are suffering we
have nothing to eat the foreign mining
companies wouldn't give us jobs they are
getting rich from our main roads but we
still were in a legal complaint the
nonprofit organization international
rights advocates accuses some of the
world's largest tech companies of being
involved in a system of forced child
labor in dr congo
the group says some children have died
mining cobalt and others have been
seriously injured many are physically
and sexually abused mothers on fossil
fuel et cetera young girls are lipped
dated it's hard to give exact number but
we know it happens a lot you can tell
they have been abused by the change in
their behavior poverty at home forces
them to come here some aren't even 14
years old and already have children
doctors say the number of people getting
sick is disturbing we have many young
boys and girls coming in to us sometimes
it's injuries from when the mines
collapse
sometimes it's sexually transmitted
diseases people don't wear protective
clothing so in women we see birth
defects and miscarriages from exposure
to the metal even rights workers say a
lack of political will is partly to
blame for success but more only will you
be there is a lack of leadership foreign
companies get away with a lot of things
sometimes they treat local communities
unfairly they get away with it because
of corruption in this country if this
changed then our people will benefit
from the resources the government says
is putting in place monitoring and
tracking mechanisms to tackle the
exploitation of children in mine
but international businesses using
cobalt in their goods under pressure
to guarantee they're not using child
labor Hera Matassa al-jazeera